all right uh a known terrorist gets
through the border or is caught at the
border it does make you wonder about the
others who are not captured the godaways
as they like to call them uh and whether
they're all just migrants trying to seek
a safer haven it's a big concern for
congressman john katko who sits on the
house homeland security committee a
ranking member there
congressman very good to have you
this is a reminder something i know
you've repeated a lot and that is that
you never know
who's trying to get through it was just
sheer luck that we got this particular
individual but there are many others we
don't and we can't because there's just
a limit um
what do you think
well uh
the the southwest border is an absolute
civ and the notion that the
administration's propounding is that
it's just underprivileged people from
mexico and central america but the fact
of the matter is people from 160
different countries have come across the
border have been seized at the border in
the last year since the biden
administration took over
and the terror watchlist individual you
talked about
uh was not seized at the border he was
led into the country fbi then alerted
border patrol uh that he was on a terror
watch list took border patrol two weeks
to go and arrest him and that's the type
of things i'm very concerned about is
they're so overwhelmed the border patrol
that they can't even when they know
someone's on a terror watch list uh it
takes them two weeks to go and arrest
him it was america they did to your
point guard it was america that they
were able to find him after two weeks
because he could have been anywhere but
it gets me back sort of this notion of
got a ways and the fact that now um it
could really get out of control title 42
or no how do you envision
this whole summer
well if title 42 goes away even
officials at homeland security have said
that as many as 18 000 people a day will
be coming across the border eighteen
thousand we have five to seven thousand
a day now and there's no doubt it's a
crisis jay johnson the former homeland
security chief uh under the obama
administration said a thousand a day
coming across a border is a bad day
we're at five to seven thousand a day
now and if title 42 is gone it's me
about eighteen thousand a day people are
massing at the border ready waiting for
this to happen
let's not forget we have uh the other
incident where they were uh an
individual plotted to kill president
george w bush that's right and part of
his scheme was to smuggle iraqis iraqis
across the southern border to help him
uh go after the president everyone knows
and the bad guys know that the borders
on fire 35 people ontario watch list
have been seized it stands the reason at
least that many have gotten across
undetected with godaways and that's
what's really scaring me yeah i was
reading congressman that now um
they
not only were able to apprehend
better than 30
individuals from india
but in the latest count and of course
these could be dated figures
those from at least 27 countries trying
to make their way here some not only as
far away as india but i'm talking
eastern europe i
what's going on
people at the southwest border have been
seized from yemen from iran from iraq
all these hotbeds of terrorism so it is
not endemic to just uh our hemisphere
and uh the the bottom line is the bad
guys know and everyone knows that the
southwest border is wide open and
everyone's trying to exploit it whether
they're trying to exploit it just to
find a better life or whether they're
trying to exploit it to do bad things in
the u.s like those on a terror watch
list
it's a mix of both but the bottom line
is this administration by the stroke
repent on january 20 when he took over
president biden he destroyed security to
southern border and it's our country's
much less safe because of it
congressman thank you very very much um
congressman john katko following these
developments here